there's a new exploit been discovered
for Linux which has got the wonderful
acronym or the wonderful names Ben if
the I to it of a dirty cow I've
downloaded an implementation that
someone put online I'm not going to tell
you where to get it from for obvious
reasons we do the rest of this video and
we'll run it and we'll see that as an
unprivileged user it'll enable me to get
root access to the system and then I'll
be able to completely destroy it and so
on so running Debian Linux VM it's not
limited just a debian basically any
version of Linux that's been released
over the last 10 years so everything
pretty much running on desktops but also
running on mobile phones such as Android
it contains this export when I got this
running on a virtual machine what we're
going to do is show that the exploit
will give us a root shell and then we
can do some things that probably
shouldn't so first of all show by trying
to change the root password that I don't
have any permissions more than the
normal user so I can't change the root
password I'm not going to run the
exploit it goes and does its stuff and
boom it's giving me a root shell and so
I can now if I move the right file back
in I can change the root password to
lemonade
copies the password file back in to the
right place logout of root and now back
at the login prompt and I can log in as
root with my password as lemonade so
I've managed to root my VM all using the
dirty cow export how would you go about
doing that so if this wasn't my machine
to use this with the implementation I've
got here you need to have an account on
the machine you need to be able to log
in and do that now you could do that
perhaps your genuine user on the system
in which case you could then run it and
perhaps do something visioned
or that you perhaps ever managed to get
hold of a username and password for
someone else's machine you can log in
run this code and suddenly boom you've
got full access to the machine and you
can do all sorts of malicious things so
this is a really serious bug that's in
Linux it's been there since about well
for at least the last ten
years and in fact there's evidence that
they did try to patch this about ten
years ago but it caused some other
problems and so it's been sitting there
this means that every mobile phone
running Android affected every Linux
machine it's there every home Rooter
every internet of things light bulb was
running Linux anything that's basically
running Linux until the last few weeks
when it was finally patched this could
be applied and there's other ways you
could do it if you could get the code
that does this onto the system using
some other exploits say running then you
could probably do it in that way it's a
really simple attack and so if you're
running Linux on anything patch your
operating system now will pause while
you go and do it and then we'll continue
so the first thing you to think about is
how linux manages memory now we've
looked at how memory works in the
computer before and basically the way
the modern system sets up its memory
when it's in x86 64 mode or x86 mode
32-bit mode